ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 4
bekanntgabe der bildung der
bundesregierung der herr bundespräsident
hat mir hierzu mit schreiben vom
heutigen tag mitgeteilt
gemäß artikel 64 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland habe ich heute auf vorschlag
des bundeskanzlers ernannt
dr robert habeck zum bundesminister für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz
christian lindner zum bundesminister der
finanzen
selters anzusehen dass sie mit ihren
trip team klatscht
leser zur bundesministerin des inneren
und für heimat
annalena baerbock zur bundesministerin
des auswärtigen
die beste frau und diesem mann gehört
schon immer so wie nancy faeser nehmen
musste
dr marco buschmann zum bundesminister
der justiz
hubertus heil zum bundesminister für
arbeit und soziales
sehr viel
mehr auf wie auch andere jona der burg
auffällig
aufbrausenden applaus hier zu hören war
christine lambrecht zur bundesministerin
der verteidigung
also wenn man nach dem applaus der spd
fraktion geht sind die präferenzen war
klar verteilt werden etwas populären
noch ist mir zum bundesminister für
ernährung und landwirtschaft
anne spiegel zur bundesministerin für
familie senioren frauen und jugend
professor doktor karl lauterbach zum
bundesminister für gesundheit
dr volker wissing zum bundesminister für
digitales und verkehr
steffi lemke zur bundesministerin für
umwelt naturschutz nukleare sicherheit
und verbraucherschutz
bettina stark watzinger zur
bundesministerin für bildung und
forschung
svenja schulze zur bundesministerin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung
klara geywitz zur bundesministerin für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
und wolfgang schmidt zum bundesminister
für besondere aufgaben
ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 5
die eidesleistung der
bundesministerinnen und bundesminister
meine damen und herren nach artikel 64
absatz 2 des grundgesetzes leisten die
bundesministerinnen und bundesminister
bei der sie können noch ein diese kurze
bewegungspause
noch kurz zurückhaltend nach artikel 64
absatz 2 des grundgesetzes leisten die
bundesministerinnen und bundesminister
bei der amtsübernahme vor dem deutschen
bundestag den in artikel 56 des
grundgesetzes vorgesehenen eilt ich
werde den eid jetzt vorsprechen und
bitte dann die mitglieder der
bundesregierung einzeln zum mikrofon und
zu kommen und den eid mit den worten ich
schwöre es so wahr mir gott helfe oder
ich schwöre es zu bekräftigen der alt
lautet ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft
dem wohle des deutschen volkes widmen
seinen nutzen mehren schaden von ihm
wenden das grundgesetz und die gesetze
des bundes wahren und verteidigen meine
pflichten gewissenhaft erfüllen und
gerechtigkeit gegen jedermann üben werde
ich darf jetzt die bundesministerin und
bundesminister zur bekräftigung des
eides zu mir zu bitten
dr robert habeck bundesminister für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz
ich schwöre es
herzlichen glückwunsch und viel erfolg
vielen dank
christian lindner bundesminister der
finanzen
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch
und alles wichtige aufgabe
nancy faeser bundesministerin des innen-
und für heimat
ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott helfe
herzlichen glückwunsch und alles
annalena baerbock bundesministerin des
auswärtigen
ich schwöre es herzlichen glückwunsch
schon alles gut
docter marco buschmann
minister der justiz
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch
und alles gute fehler auf
hubertus heil bundesminister für arbeit
und soziales
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch
und alles gute für ihre aufgaben
christine lambrecht bundesministerium
der verteidigung
frau präsidentin schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch
cem özdemir bundesminister für ernährung
und landwirtschaft
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es
vielen dank klassen glück wurde ich
immer alles gute für ihre aufgaben
anne spiegel bundesministerin für
familie senioren frauen und jugend
frau präsidentin ich würde es herzlichen
glückwunsch und alles bricht
professor doktor karl lauterbach
minister bundesminister für gesundheit
frau präsidentin nicht los so wahr mir
gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch schon
alles klar
dr volker wissing bundesminister für
digitales im verkehr
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe alles gute für ihre
aufgaben herzlichen willkommen
steffi lemke bundesministerin für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz frau präsidentin ich
schwöre es herzlichen glückwunsch und
alles wichtige aufgabe
bettina stark watzinger bundesministerin
für bildung und forschung
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch
schon alles gute für
svenja schulze bundesministerin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es
herzlichen glückwunsch und alles durch
ihre aufgabe
klara geywitz bundesministerin für
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe herzlichen glückwunsch
und alles gute
wolfgang schmidt bundesminister für
besondere aufgaben
frau präsidentin ich schwöre es
herzlichen glückwunsch und alles gute
für ihre aufgaben
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren die mitglieder
der bundesregierung haben den nach
artikel 64 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
vorgeschriebene neid vor dem deutschen
bundestag geleistet ich spreche den
mitgliedern der bundesregierung
persönlich und auch im namen des hauses
die besten wünsche für die übernommenen
aufgaben aus
wir sind damit am schluss dieser
tagesordnung dieses besonderen tages und
ich berufe die nächste sitzung des
deutschen bundestages ein auf morgen
donnerstag den 9 dezember 9 uhr die
sitzung ist geschlossen
ja und damit haben wir eine neue
bundesregierung
dieser tag bietet ja wenig platz für
freiraum nico fried haben sie das gefühl
dass die neue bundesregierung trotzdem
sich schon abheben konnte von der alten
also ich fand es interessant zu
verfolgen gerade bei der eidesleistung
wer die gottesformel verwendet hat und
wer nicht
wir haben wenn wir hier richtig
mitgezählt haben haben neun mit
so wahr mir gott helfe und 7 ohne von
diesen sieben waren alle sechs grünen
minister oder fünf grünen-minister das
interesse an tschuldigung fünf grünen
minister ohne die gottesformel und in
der spd doch sehr viele gerd schröder
den wir vorhin im interview gesehen hat
war der erste bundeskanzlerin den ohne
gottes vor mir gesprochen hat der werder
sicher nicht so begeistert davon gewesen
wie christlich überzeugt seine spd
fraktion gehalt zwischen geworden ist
haben wir eben gesehen auch noch das ist
hier ja auch noch ein paar glückwünsche
gibt aber
jetzt verlassen natürlich auch viele
abgeordnete den plenarsaal
denn auch das hat ja bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas gesagt ich
erwartet ja auch viel arbeit auf die
abgeordneten
wie entwickelt sich dann das christliche
bild in der regierungspolitik
zeigen wird das werden wir dann ja in
den nächsten jahren
erfahren es war jetzt zum schluss
relativ voll natürlich das will ich noch
mal nachfragen weil ich finde wie gesagt
habe dass es doch noch einige leere
reihen gab aber auch deshalb werbe war
es gesagt das ist ja ein besonderer tag
auch und hier das ist auch interessant
der
außenpolitiker der fdp graf lambsdorff
im gespräch mit der neuen
außenministerin annalena baerbock es ist
ja auch interessant zu hören was die
wohl jetzt noch kurz besprochen haben ja
die werden jetzt öfter miteinander zu
tun haben ich nehme an dass
der name ist dort die zuständigkeit für
die außenpolitik behält und dann auch
der außenministerin häufiger begegnen
wird karl lauterbach übrigens die
eidesformel mit gottes
gesprochen hat mich überrascht ehrlich
gesagt
und ihr saskia esken die spd-vorsitzende
mein gott wer hätte das gedacht als die
gewählt wurde zur parteivorsitzenden
dass olaf scholz überhaupt noch eine
chance auf die kanzlerkandidatur
haben würde
interessant ja und auch karl lauterbach
das können wir ja schon mal sagen der
wird auch heute tatsächlich gleich ihm
das amt die amtsübergabe machen um 16
usd angekündigt dass er das amt vom
bisherigen gesundheitsminister jens
spahn
übernehmen wird das hatte man auch das
gefühl das ja gar nicht warten kann bis
er loslegen kann und hier in der
pandemie seine politik umsetzen möchte
da gibt es ja auch viel drüber
er handlungsbedarf
ja wenn er hier in spanien treffen wird
das ist auch eine
merkwürdige beziehung die beiden kennen
sich ja sehr sehr lange schon die haben
ja früher auch schon als abgeordnete
beide
gesundheitspolitik gemacht haben sich
bekämpft aber auch vieles gemeinsam
gemacht und es gab ja vor einigen
monaten eine pressekonferenz jens spahn
hatte ja bei seinen wöchentlichen
pressekonferenzen mit erker chef wieder
immer oder häufig auch einen gast dazu
gehörten da war es auch einmal karl
lauterbach und da ging es auch um die
frage ob er eigentlich mal
gesundheitsminister werden könnte da hat
ja dann damals noch kein mensch daran
gedacht
ja und während es hier noch die letzten
umarmungen gibt was ja auch in unserer
heutigen zeit man nicht so oft sieht
aber an einem solchen tag da da ist es
ja dann wahrscheinlich doch so dass man
dann sagt er wenn man sich drückt dann
noch heute wenn eben dort die
parteikollegen hier solche posten
übernehmen das ist ja schon eine
feierstunde da sieht man hier auch
nochmal annalena baerbock die neue
außenministerin wie sie hier
beglückwünscht wird
da mit dem goldenen kleid war saß
angeblich
noch staatssekretärin in berlin die
vertritt hier michael mann hat er ja
noch der regierende bürgermeister ist
aber auch
bundestagsabgeordnete und natürlich am
heutigen tag das machen musste
so und wir verlassen den bunte dass
pläne den plenarsaal
erst einmal den erschaffer hat einen
neuen gast bei sich